no
[Music]
jingles
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
down
[Music]
that's
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
be
it is
it is
[Music]
i carry you with me i just curious the
title heidi just tell us for a beat
was that always in your mind is the the
title of this movie
or i called it for many years i call it
the arrivals before the movie arrival
came out the science fiction movie oh
yes okay immediately that but you know i
would have had to change the title
anyway because
i started to think about this movie
under under barack obama in a different
kind of world
and somehow calling it the arrivals
somehow i had some kind of like
political
they're arriving but i don't know
somehow it wouldn't
for months i was reading mexican poetry
and spanish poetry and trying to find a
title that would work in both languages
and i carry you with me i was tricky to
find a title that worked in both
but for me the movie is about memory uh
and about what we give up and what we
bring with us and so in the end i kind
of like that there was like multiple
meetings of
of i carry with me i carry with my heart
i carry with me to the united states
so in the end i settled on that but very
very late
the process just just before sundance
yeah
it's poignant it's bittersweet right but
there's so much love in this movie so
tell me how
um armando and and heidi and and
how you guys met and sort of the genesis
of this
it feels almost like the intersection of
a great documentary and a great
narrative
scripted feature so how did that all
come together
well i'm making documentaries for a lot
of years and so
um with my first narrative i you know
i i felt like this needed a narrative
treatment this story even though it's
based on
two really good friends of mine it's a
true story um but it's such an epic and
there's so much love and romance that i
felt that it really
needed the narrative treatment and so i
went to the business of writing the
screenplay
but what i didn't want to do in making
my first narrative
is abandon um you know an aesthetic that
i've
that i've that i've come to enjoy and
also the
the concept of voyeurism which um i've
been practicing for many many years
something about this
film needed that voyeurism um there are
people
you know doing things slightly
clandestinely and are meeting up
furtively and
living in a conservative town in the
early 90s
surrounded by risk risk of losing a job
or
family or one son not necessarily
you know overt physical risk i didn't
want to conflate it
but sort of the idea of observing and
flowing
and sort of the camera not anticipating
what was going to happen next
that was a big thing that i discussed a
lot with
um with my cinematographer juan pablo
ramirez which was like we didn't you
know we didn't
rehearse on the um like we would
rehearse in advance but we didn't do
blocking for example
which i don't know if that was different
for armando he should probably speak to
that
but i really wanted the takes to shoot
the rehearsal basically on
on the set so we could sort of try to
get that unanticipated feeling
throughout the film which is kind of
tricky to do i realized when you do
multiple takes
and when things would get sort of stale
we would start improvising the last tape
was always improvised
and often i used that take so armando i
don't know
process yeah it was with heidi um it was
everything new every day she always
wanted to try new things
and new ways to do the same things it
was crazy it was a huge learning that i
got from this movie to just to
be open uh on whatever i mean
we built this trust to each other
in order to really collaborate yeah
so yeah every time heidi asks something
new and crazy
because she used to do that a lot i just
knew that
that she uh knew what he wanted
to achieve um sometimes i didn't
understand why but it was uh it was nice
to just let myself go and not think that
much and not
asking so many questions just just just
be in the situation um and it's
beautiful because heidi
likes to play adi likes to have the
material a lot of kinds of material and
just to play
and put the pieces in different orders
uh but i was so
so so glad when i finally watched the
movie and
i got to see the the feeling of
nostalgia in every shoot and
you can sometimes maybe it's because i
did it but
uh i could smell i could feel these
nails in the
in the textures of things and in the
lighting so
it was kind of a puzzle for me just to
make the movie and then watch it it was
kind of
how do you came up with this it was it
was nice
to work with heidi said let's talk about
the scene
yeah where was that was that in mexico
city or puebla you were in a gay bar
well the scene um that was a dilapidated
a
vacated mansion falling apart in mexico
city but it's supposed to be playable it
looks like puebla
and basically it's based on the telling
of the story by my friends ivana gerardo
is how they met
um they're including the laser pointer
because gerardo was a teacher he had the
laser pointer in his briefcase
he had this cute idea and i always was
charmed by the laser pointer i thought
it was charming i thought it was cute it
was
fun funny wonderful yeah idea you know
and
um in fact that was the crew gift was a
laser pointer with the name of the film
on it
that everybody got to use for flirting
in the future and so i
was like by the that flirtatious like
audacious little move
and um yeah it was actually the real bar
frank who was now gone the roof fell in
puebla but we had a lot of fun scouting
and looking for the exact right
spot where like if you walk by you don't
really know anything's going you got to
know that there's a bar in there you
know it was like
a part of that like little subculture um
and
well armando can tell you our rehearsal
process for that but the idea was
show not tell and i wrote a 115 page
script and the final
shooting script of the final film is 70
pages
all told because we just kept taking
dialogue away and going
so i that's something that our motto and
christian and i worked on a lot
that was actually one of the audition
scenes
remember heidi it was one of the first
things that i got access to
um and it was cute it was cute just to
imagine the the
later point just using that for
for flirting is it was fun it was cute
but then we have a lot of we used to had
a lot of
text around it do you remember heidi at
the beginning
a lot of conversations and we did a lot
of um
rehearsal because of too much talking
yes
yeah too much talk and we did some
rehearsals with that material
and it was so helpful because it was our
first introduction to the characters and
it was so helpful
just to know what they are think and say
and then just to
not say anything just let
yourself think uh on the action
and it was so fun because heidi shoot
though
the same thing the same thing in
different situations and moments
yeah so just to put yourself in
in some in automatic way i don't know
how to say that
in english but see
when you just let yourself go and
if they change your location to do the
same thing
what things changed on you it was so fun
it was so fun to do i felt bad that i
made you do that because in the end i
did it so simply in the final editing
lisa i was i'm a big fan of the limey
and i always loved how
steven soderbergh recorded the same
scene in like six locations and then he
would intercut
and he would use the cutaway during the
like i would be talking to you and you'd
only see my reaction during my dialogue
i call it the limey cut i've done it
like once in a documentary and i've
always
thought oh this isn't good because it's
all about what are they thinking what
are they
what is the expression on their face
does the dialogue really matter
so we shot the same scene in four
different parts of the mansion
and and i was intercutting it and i
realized
that for an act one scene it was too
showy
i was it was like to process it was i
was taking away from the meeting
by running the scene so i learned also
as a director to just
simplify stop trying to show off and do
why me
and do something cool don't do the cool
let's develop these guys let's create
the sex appeal between them so also as a
director i failed at this thing i tried
which we rehearsed a lot and i think it
helped the performances
but in the end it's a pretty simple
straightforward one location
in the bathroom scene but you know i
think that's
i think simplicity is like
underestimated and
um you know as a moviegoer sometimes you
just
want to be absorbed in in a moment
yeah and it was universal it was a
universal language and i think that's
the strength
um of all of it of your work of your
work armando and just of the concept of
the film
thank you i i think heidi i
heidi made me feel that she wanted to
watch something from us
from christian and i um not the
characters
except it was a mix between the
characters and what we have
together christina and i as actors as
human beings
so for me all the play that she was
doing
and you had it making us do the scene in
different ways
it was helpful because i got to
understand that you want
something different each time and i was
to i needed to be open
to give you that so it was flattering in
a way just to
understand that you wanted a mix of both
the actor and the character uh i mean i
i think that's nice we had fun
every day they would show up and
christian who couldn't be with us today
would say oh god let's play what are we
going to do
and so it became sort of like play time
after yeah
and that was where we started getting
real cooking with gas i thought when
everyone was like
how we how should we you know there was
a definitely a freeing for all of us and
it was so nice
me as a first time narrative director to
have people down to try stuff
well i think that's where your great you
know experience and skill as a
documentarian
knowing kind of feeling in your gut what
is authentic what does it look like
that's what you go out and do with the
documentary right and
i might be wrong in reading into it but
watching it i
really felt that and i felt you as a
filmmaker
doing something very skillful that that
i admired a lot
well thank you so much i mean it was
very obviously i it was scary for me
i've been making films for a long time
but there is that chasm between the
and it shouldn't be minimized you know
uh that
that learning gap also between the two
forms
um and i had never directed actors
before so
i was very very lucky that the actors
that the cast
was willing to kind of go along with me
um and
trust in the process um you know i was
changing things i i co-wrote the movie
as well so
in rehearsal we would change dialogue
and things because certain things i
could tell weren't coming out the right
way even though the spanish was perfect
in the script and so i worked a lot with
the actors um
asking them their personal stories and
things like that as well so there was a
lot of conversation about accuracy
um and i asked please help me get it
right if this doesn't feel right you
must tell me
obviously i make the final call but in
terms of just how it's feeling and does
this feel real and would you say it a
different way and
hugely important you didn't want to get
that wrong so luckily
it was based on true events and so i was
able to meet the original owner of the
bar
the real kakuza and so everyone was very
much
um i won't say policing that doesn't
sound fun super like
let's help her get it right let's make
fun that
um and i wanted them to feel like it's a
mexican film and they do so
that was really like a big big part of
shooting in mexico's making sure that i
was getting guidance
yeah for me it had a universal
feeling and i'm really glad that people
are going to be able to
to see it 2021 baby
oh my god it's gonna be better i hope
so you guys good good good luck with the
movie
um i really wish you all the best i
think it's just beautifully done i've
said it a few times but um
bravo